[MUSIC PLAYING]
EMILY FORTUNA: Joining us now
is Yossi Matias, Vice President
of Engineering at Google and
the head of the Google R&D
Center in Israel.
Thanks for being here, Yossi.
YOSSI MATIAS: Thank you
very much for inviting me.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Yossi, you're involved
with AI for social good.
And you've worked on
an impressive number
of projects surrounding that.
How did you get into that area?
How did it start up here?
YOSSI MATIAS: So in a way, we
were working on social good
from the early days in Google.
It's part of the
DNA of the company
to try and use technology to
solve problems for people.
And obviously, in the last
couple of years, where AI
is getting a lot of--
we became an AI first company.
And AI had all
these advancements.
So suddenly, we started looking
into how to leverage on AI,
how to use it to solve those
societal problems that can help
out people in a profound way.
EMILY FORTUNA: And
specifically, you've
worked on flood prediction.
And in my experience,
predicting the future
is not a task best
left to mere mortals.
So I'm curious.
You could tell us how
you got started on that
and how it actually works.
YOSSI MATIAS: Sure.
Yeah.
There's an old saying that
prediction is hard, especially
about the future.
So I've been
leading a team which
is working on crisis response,
where the mission of the team
is to develop technologies to
help people during crisis--
natural disasters
and other crisis--
by providing the right
information to people.
And in fact, my
involvement in that,
going back 8 and 1/2
years, where as a user,
I had the experience.
We had a devastating
fire in Israel.
And it was near
our Haifa office.
We have offices in
Tel Aviv and Haifa.
I was visiting that day.
And I didn't know what
I should be doing.
I saw this huge smoke.
I didn't find any
information on the internet.
And this was actually
the first time
that I experienced the
need for information.
And it was not until I actually
called the mayor's office
that I got the phone number
of actionable information.
And in fact, at that
time, I asked my team
to see how to make
that information
available to everybody.
And within a few hours, anybody
searching for fire in Israel
could get that information.
So this was the
first example where
we gave kind of actionable
information to people.
Now, fast forward--
now we integrated
into Search something
we call SOS Alerts,
which essentially provides
information about major crisis
when they happen.
And one thing we discovered
is that we can only
give information which we have.
But one of the most devastating
natural disaster are floods.
They impact up to 250
million people per year.
And there are thousands of
fatalities because of them.
And in many cases, we don't have
information about where floods
exactly is going to occur.
So we knew this is
important problem.
But it wasn't clear
whether we can actually
do anything about it.
There was an engineer
that just joined.
And he said he wants to
work on a project that
could help save lives.
And I asked him, well, why don't
you spend part of your time
seeing how much we can advance
using AI and other technologies
in order to help out
with flood forecasting?
And within a few months,
he made enough progress
that we actually built
a team around it.
And in less than a
year, actually, it
was ready as a pilot in
the partner area in India.
And that's how actually the
flood forecasting effort
came to life.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
And when you first
started looking at that problem,
did you think it was solvable?
YOSSI MATIAS: So actually, when
I had the discussion with him,
I told him that I'm
not sure if we're
going to be able to solve it,
because in order to really--
and we were focusing on really
what we call riverine floods.
These are floods where the river
starts rising because of water.
Then you know then there's
likely going to be some floods.
But the important
information to know
is exactly where the
flood is going to occur,
because it's only then that
people will take action.
It's only then that
people would evacuate,
or it's only then
where government
can take action and
evacuate the right people
from the right places.
Now, in order to get these
accurate predictions,
there's a lot going on.
You need to have relatively
fresh information about where
the water already is in order
to make the predictions.
We are leveraging
on the fact that we
have better elevation
models for many more
places around the world.
And that elevation
model itself is
computed with some of
the best technologies.
Machine learning on aerial
imagery and the other data
that we have, it's using a
lot of computational power
to do hydraulic simulations
and complemented also
with machine
learning techniques.
And it's using
information that we're
getting through a partnership
with the Indian government,
where they're actually measuring
the water level in quite
a few rivers and
trying to actually make
sense of what's going on there.
So this is really
a true partnership
with the Indian
government on that.
And as it turns out, we could
actually get into prediction
a few hours before the floods
actually get into the level
that it did of over 90%
accuracy, which was actually
quite impactful.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah,
that's hugely impactful.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
How were you able to connect
with the Indian government
and get these people
involved in the project?
YOSSI MATIAS: The
beauty is that once we
started working on that,
there's a lot of interest
to collaborate.
And I would say that on many
of the societal problems,
the notion of collaboration
between companies
and communities and
entrepreneurs and governments,
I think this is one
of the areas that we
need to see more of, because
these are big problems.
And we do need to have
this kind of community
effort and global effort, in
order to really tackle them.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's cool.
EMILY FORTUNA: Thank
you so much, Yossi.
And thank you for helping
create this environment
to be able to make
these products possible.
YOSSI MATIAS: It's
a privilege to be
able to have this
kind of environment
and to work with people who care
about how to use technologies
to solve big problems.
[MUSIC PLAYING]